[Musique]
avec vous elle en fera bon jour hélène
bonjour pauline une revue de presse
consacrée aux enseignements donc de ce
second tour des élections législatives
ici en france des élections au cours
desquelles le camp présidentiel a donc
perdu la majorité absolue à l'assemblée
nationale moins de deux mois après la
présidentielle les électeurs ont donc
dit non et emmanuel mâcon qui avait
pourtant demandé une majorité solide
pour gouverner un séisme d'après les
échos qui voit déjà la france bloquée
l'actuel gouvernement condamné le
gratuit 20 minutes parle d'une douche
froide pour le chef de l'état désormais
pris en étau entre la nuque l'alliance
de la gauche devenue principale force
d'opposition et le rassemblement
national dont la percée à l'assemblée
est historique avec près de 90 députés
contre 8 en 2007 la gifle le titre
libération d'après le journal le paie le
président paie sa stratégie de l'
esquive durant la campagne mèze les
électeurs or est aussi sanctionné ce qui
est l'essence même du maquereau nisme sa
prétention à aspirer à la fois la gauche
et la droite un positionnement qui aura
finalement contribué à nourrir des
oppositions radicales ou extrêmes à
l'issue de ces législatives et là ne
vous l'avais dit aucun compte toutefois
de réunir la majorité absolue au
parlement mais la croix évoque un
paysage politique éclaté mais aussi
barré par le brouillard d'une abstention
massive près de 54% le journal
s'inquiète de ce que ce manque de clarté
puisse déboucher sur une instabilité
politique alors que la france doit
affronter des défis immenses la guerre
en europe mais également la question du
réchauffement climatique ou encore la
hausse des taux d'intérêt ce synonyme de
pressions accrues sur les dettes
publiques le figaro se demande comment
le président va pouvoir gouverner l'un
gouvernable face à une assemblée qui
risque de se transformer le site en
chaudron bouillonnant de passion un
accord de coalition avec la droite est
il possible sonnera-t-il dégager au cas
par cas des majorités à géométrie
variable
le journal évoque déjà le risque pour
emmanuel macron de rester dans
l'histoire comme le spectateur
impuissant d'un quinquennat mots avant
même d'avoir commencé
huit semaines après sa réélection
emmanuel macron aura besoin de trouver
des alliés pour gouverner d'après le
parisien aujourd'hui en france le danger
qui guette et donne est désormais celui
de l'immobilisme que la france avait
connu jadis sous la quatrième république
tels commentaires à l'être en allemagne
le frankfurter allgemeine zeitung voit
dans ces résultats une sanction du style
d' emmanuel macron ce jeune président
qui a trop souvent bafoué le parlement
durant son premier mandat en prenant ses
décisions seul dans un petit cercle sans
tenir sa promesse électorale de réformes
et de réformes et de renforcer plutôt
l'assemblée nationale le quotidien
allemand relève lui aussi que le chef de
l'état a évité le débat de fond durant
la campagne marquée en revanche par
plusieurs polémiques les accusations de
viol contre le ministre des solidarités
damien abad réélu malgré tout et le
chaos lors de la finale de la ligue des
champions au stade de france des
polémiques qui aurait accru la méfiance
des français envers le camp présidentiel
selon le quotidien allemand au liban
l'orient-le jour souligner
l'affaiblissement donc d' emmanuel
macron mais aussi la percée historique
du rassemblement national de l'extrême
droite présenté comme un revers majeur
pour le président la presse étrangère
hélène qui s'interrogent elles aussi sur
la façon dont le président macron va
pouvoir ou ne va pas pouvoir plutôt le
journal suisse le temps évoque même
menace de paralysie et même un risque de
blocage monstre pour ce second mandat le
quotidien établi un parallèle historique
entre la situation d'aujourd'hui celle
qui s'était imposée à françois
mitterrand 1981 vite à l'époque son
premier ministre michel rocard avait
gouverné sans majorité absolue emmanuel
macron devra lui aussi chercher des
alliances on l'a dit avec d'autres
forces politiques avec la possibilité qu
émerge à la fois des frondeurs qui
joueront sa politique trop à droite ou
trop à gauche en belgique le soir parle
d'un cauchemar pour emmanuel macron
accusé je cite d'avoir joué avec le feu
il se rêvait tant président faure il
doit maintenant se transformer en
pompier pour sauver ce qui peut l'être
singles le quotidien belge juge les
résultats de ces législatives
inquiétant aussi pour l'europe avec la
france qui se réveille ingouvernable
c'est la seule puissance nucléaire de
l'union qui est affaibli le soir se
demande comment va se positionner la
france dans les crises actuelles la
guerre en ukraine le plan de relance
économique et la crise environnementale
avec une assemblée aussi divisé et qui
n'a sans doute jamais été aussi anti
européenne merci beaucoup hélène c'était
la revue de presse à tout à l'heure dans
paris direct si vous nous rejoignez sur
l'antenne de france 24 nous en rappelle
l'une des principales informations on en
parlait à l'instant avec hélène la
recomposition de l'assemblée nationale
ici en france à l'issue du second tour
des élections législatives manuel macron
a perdu la majorité absolue dans
l'hémicycle la nuque la coalition de la
gauche devient la première force
d'opposition et si en france à noter
également le score historique obtenue
par l'extrême droite le rassemblement
national qui obtient 89 députés à
l'issue de ce scrutin on va y revenir
largement bien sûr tout au long de cette
matinée d'un faux mais tous